Là on est à 215 000, les deux maisons qui sont à coté sont parties en une semaine voire 15 jours, on va aller visiter y'a une grande surface.
C'est l'Halloween, on veut des bonbons.
Mais que c'est joli !
Mon dieu cette dentelle!  Ooooooh!
AAAAAAAH!
*bêlement*
C'est trop calme...
J'aime pas trop beaucoup ça.
*musique angoissante*
Oh mon dieu, c'est le monstre!
J'ai envie de dire un truc, mais je me souviens plus ce que c'est.
Ce serait pas ''Aaaaaaaaaaaaaah'' par hasard?
C'est ça.
AAAAAAAAAH!
Attention!
Je te rappelle, c'est affreux!
Aieeeeeee heuuuuuuuuuuu.
Ta mère suce des queues en enfer!
C'est à moi que tu m'exprimes?
Baise moi ! Baise moi !
Non ! Ne.. Ne me touche pas !
Oh non!
Vous avez commencé la visite sans moi!
Hey, vous avez même fait la connaissance du propriétaire!
Airnadette,  on y va, faut se lancer, on achète hein!
Puis elle est pas mortelle cette maison?
Hein?
Mortelle non?